so here is a clip of a woman getting
rejected on whatever podcast because she
did porn let's pull it up I actually
like you like I would I literally have
said like I would sign an NDA and like
never like let people know about our
relationship but like I actually like
actually like you so confirm or deny are
you a pathological liar but I'm not a
anymore I don't do porn anymore
but I I literally said I would stop
being a for you and I literally
stopped porn listen you're an attractive
woman but the fact that you've done porn
and it was a hiccup
it is a 100% a deal breaker like but I
said I'm sorry and I literally quit
being a thought your thank you for your
apology and like my P he like I accept I
accept your apology for doing porn Okay
um yeah it's just not going to happen
Brian why like because I used to be a
like used to you still
[Music]
are she's so funny actually the one girl
has to chime in you still are